to workshop in a moment but but I thank
them for putting the program together
also thank you to the Institute for
business and social impact for their
support of the program throughout the
semester I want to say a few words about
logistics before we start so we do try
to keep the auditorium clean so please
don't bring food and coffee and tea in
here what is fine you can finish those
other things outside we'd be grateful
you've discovered those tea and coffee
and snacks that were there at this time
of day in the morning and in the
afternoon you're on your own for lunches
but there is a list of places to go
outside on the table there also lockers
available bu so much time on the far
side of the building with the pin codes
to do to get into those you want to do
stuff hopefully you've discovered why
fight opposite is the good one and you
can also use injury your institution
supports authentication that way the
tools are all going to be live streamed
and archived on the website and on
YouTube now the other part is Derek room
here you'll be topping with looking out
computers and their speakers to sign a
waiver forms also our event coordinator
Jessie Gill that the back of the room
would be thank you to the Jessie for
always working on a local
took over from comma well gee who is
also around this morning for that for
that transition do a lot of a lot of
work for this workshop but do feel free
to ask Jesse or Coble if you have any
questions about logistics all right so
thank you everybody for coming
I'm very excited about the topic there
are about ten speakers that I know
personally and another ten the other
half of the program I haven't met so my
first chance to get to meet all of you
I think the topic really brings computer
scientists economists
vilasa furs lawyers together and so I'm
really hoping for there to be sort of
active discussion so feel free to
interrupt our first speaker which will
be
[Applause]
okay okay good morning hi and thanks for
the organizers for inviting here I'm
always extremely happy to be back in
this building in particular after
especially after spending a whole
semester here last year the target that
was put on the schedule I did not give
it but it's not a complete miss I will
talk about things related to law and
computer science but in a much more
restricted sense I don't understand
about the law it's a very wide topic and
I also understand in computer science
unlimited so I'll focus on relationship
between law and computer science in the
context of privacy and I will tell about
this project which is an ongoing project
we have some initial results that I
won't mention here but this has been
running for the last about six years
beginning at the time I was at Harvard
and continuing now when I mean
Georgetown University and its
collaboration were with the
participation of computer scientists and
legal scholars and social scientists on
do please feel free to stop me with
questions for me I will not know the
answers I have to say again I'm I'm not
a lawyer so I need in this kind of work
to to collaborate with legal scholars
and because they complement my
understanding and hopefully I complement
their understanding so that we can
hopefully do something new which is in
in between the disciplines and this is
what I wanted to talk about today
so the privacy problem just for
motivation we collect a lot of personal
data companies do the government's to
that virus institutions do that but this
is not just for the mirror collection
but also to make use of this data so in
the most abstract way we put that data
into some computation or analysis
sometime this is referred to a mechanism
and we get an outcome and this outcome
and then is hopefully useful for
scientific findings or policymaking in
the national security and so on
and privacy question is whatever we can
do this we can whatever we can use the
data compute interesting functions of
the data set but considering the fact
that this data contains sensitive
personal information can we do that
while protecting privacy and the focus
that they want to have today is what the
heck does this mean while protecting
individual privacy
now trying to answer this question we
can look at what we currently have in
the literature and I will bring trials
to answer the question what is privacy
what does it mean to protect privacy
coming both from the technical
literature computer science literature
and from the legal literature so in the
technical literature we'll see what I
would call technical privacy concepts
and two examples are key and limiting
and differential privacy and I will give
a very brief introduction to to to the
to our concepts in a few minutes and but
when you look at them these are concepts
that attempt to give to offer some
general privacy protection usually they
are not considered in a specific context
they are not devised to answer privacy
issues of a specific context but much
more generally in principle you could
apply differential privacy or anonymity
in any context where an individual data
is being collected and analyzed they use
mathematical language not surprisingly
they will come from a field that uses
math as the language of communication
and this description of what we do and
furthermore as a language that we use to
argue about these concepts it seeks to
provide provable privacy guarantees and
and manages to do that to some extent
and on the other hand when we look at
the legal literature we see also many
legal privacy concepts you will not see
anonymity and differential privacy
directly there these appear in in legal
texts and in particular in regulations
and laws that some of them are directly
talking about privacy in some of them
privacy is part of the requirements that
this document is that these documents
are describing for instance FERPA and
HIPAA are two u.s. regulations two of
the very many regulations
the us that touch on privacy of
individual information trip is about
educational records HIPPA is not a legal
standard of privacy but it does have
have a word it refers to privacy this is
about medical information and we all
heard about I guess about the digit PR
that in you standard that was enacted in
in May last year this which is more
general this is stop now FERPA and HIPAA
are very context are about very specific
context like educational records or
medical records were the GDP are listen
its name its general data protection
regulation and I'll try to talk about
the gtp our little later and when you
look in this documents you see a
plethora of legal privacy concepts such
as PII personally identifiable
information an idea that you could be
identify or anonymized data notion of
link ability singling out risk insurance
rates opt-out concerned and a few more
concept like that that make up like the
soup from which these documents are
choosing and and these are the concept
that they use in order to define their
privacy requirements I should say that
okay before I say that the Indian
definition of these concepts is not
formal or accurate or regular or
mathematical point of view and this is
often very painful when people like me
are looking at this when computer
scientists are looking at this trying to
get the rig or here and translate that
into mathematical language and it is
sometimes or often frustrating but
nevertheless this is what we have to
deal with
it's often sector-based at least in the
u.s. it's not general it leaves the
definitions live significant very areas
and uncertainty with respect to what
exactly they capture in many times
definitions include some extreme
examples like clearly if you take
personal sensitive information and
publish it in in in the public ok this
is not good and clearly if you just
maybe burn it this is privacy preserving
but not good from a utility point of
view but what happens in the middle is
hard to it's hard to put the line of
where exactly we consider the the the
treatment of data are private privacy
preserving and when when when the
treatment exceeds this boundary and also
sometimes these concepts are seem to be
in disagreement with what we currently
understand scientifically about
information about privacy and I should
also say that this concept that I
colored yellow here are sometimes many
times redefined in the different
documents and these definitions are not
always consistent between themselves
because each of the regulation
especially when we talk about the sector
base regulation they care about some
other things and they emphasize other
things and this can create some mismatch
between there are definitions of the
same concept
so taking these two parts of the puzzle
the best would be if we can just put
them together because you know more and
more data is being processed by computer
systems so these technical privacy
concepts that we use hopefully match the
the legal concept so hopefully we can
very easily claim that the use of these
or other concepts meets the requirements
of the of the of the law but trying to
put them together I found it quite hard
to match these pieces they don't fit
together and hence maybe what we need is
a new piece that will help to bridge
between these legal and technical 5g
concepts this is what I will try to to
talk about today and hopefully I'll show
you that we have some definitely there
there are a lot of difficulties but
there are also some reasons for optimism
some some results that we can actually
or some some examples or a couple of
examples where we can actually
contribute to this piece that that is
here in the middle
and as I said this is an ongoing project
it began at Harvard when I was in the
privacy tooth project there I visited 40
years and there we were worried that so
in the privacy tooth project we were
building tools for social scientists to
share sensitive information that they
collect throughout their research with
other scientists and we were worried and
we were suggesting before being worried
we were suggesting the use of
differentially private tools too as a
means for helping this sharing and we
were worried whether once we'll will
actually start using this would real
data whether this use of differentially
private analysis actually complies with
the legal restrictions that that there
are in purple in particular with respect
to sensitive information in people with
respect to educational records that was
a use case for us and so we want to make
rigorous claims that the use of official
privacy actually satisfies the legal
requirements but over time and the goal
has been updated and currently we're
trying more broadly to understand how
the legal and technical concepts of
privacy
how these relate to each other and
bridge between the two languages and
bridging between the languages is not
only in terms of defining the concepts
but also hopefully in terms of building
ways to argue about privacy and in
arguments that hopefully make sense both
from a legal and technical point of view
so want to compute the legal analysis
technical analysis in to combine these
in our argument
so some positive things said about this
project in the last four years I meet
more and more with legal scholars and
this is what's actually said about this
project it's a total waste of time and
some lawyers would say I can easily
literally litigate the use of depression
privacy in court by just making a claim
that this is the technology that
currently scholars and experts agree is
the best we have in order to to to
provide privacy and hence its use should
be legitimate from a legal point of view
I want to say that this is not the point
I think and the entire discussion today
is not about differential privacy I'm
not trying to push differential privacy
as a concept what I'm trying to push is
the idea that we need to find a way to
bridge between concepts like
differential privacy and the concepts
that appear in the law and we need to
understand how to relate to each other
not only with respect to legal concept
but like to how we think about privacy
in other society so I'm happy to hear
that also in this audience or in this
workshop there will be people coming
from ethics and philosophy to talk about
privacy we need to understand how the
way we think about privacy normatively
how that interacts with the technical
measures that we are giving in order to
provide privacy okay otherwise we're
just doing something maybe arbitrary and
one could claim that it's an impossible
task and I would tend to agree but
nevertheless I think that we don't have
any any option but to try to tackle it
and maybe we will never get there but
hopefully with this kind of work we'll
get closer to to an ideal where we have
this understanding and I also think that
we need to do this would Adams match
rigor as possible in order not to make
past mistake
we have by now a litany of I don't know
how many years probably a few decades
where we used technology that was
supposed to provide privacy but was
shown not to provide privacy in any
reasonable way although it was also easy
to litigate the dis technology in court
that this technology satisfies the legal
requirements ok so this is what I'll try
to do I cut this presentation for a much
longer one but and and I made a lot of
compromising in doing that but so in
particular this part of the background
related work is going to be very short I
think I had three or four slides and
then I want to show one example one use
case of work of how we do how we tackle
this question of creating this this
region so for background related work I
will mention very briefly about these
two technologies community and
differential privacy and then the
specific technical details are not going
to be important for the talk so but so
don't worry about that
and then I will review a few works that
try to do something in this in the vein
that that I'm talking about okay so what
is Karen limited this is the concept
that was suggested by Latanya Sweeney
and Sumati in around the year 2000 and
Calamity actually was devised in order
to answer a very specific kind of attack
in the year 2000 the times when he
showed that she could reify information
that was the identified she and that was
real life information from Massachusetts
and she actually managed to identify the
medical records of the person who was
then the
governor of Massachusetts and put it in
an envelope and sent it to his address
and calamity was a way to a is a measure
to avoid the specific kind of attack
that Sweeney developed them and and that
the she that she managed to identify the
information would okay so in coming to
bouquet take a data set and we use
operations that we call suppression
organization the idea is that we erase
information from the data okay the data
is the data of personal records and we
will decide to suppress information or
to generalize it generalizing means like
if there is an age maybe we will round
it or we'll we'll back it it within like
multiple of five or something like that
and the goal is that in if in the
original dataset every individual would
usually be different will have a
different row into their certain hands
could be identified by by that row in
the kanima tea will require that after
the suppression generalization every row
that that appears in the outcome will
appear at least k times let me give you
an example let's say this is a fake
medical record of course and you can see
that if you use the agents X you could
use them to identify people and if you
say you live in zip code two three four
five six and you're you know 35-year old
neighborhood happens to be a female you
know that she went to this hospital then
you know that she had a heart condition
okay so you can actually identify her
role in in this data set now with
we to anonymize the data and here I
suppress some of the data and some of
the information and generalize some of
the information in the agency that this
person is in his thirties okay but now
every row appears if you will check this
every row appears twice in the desert
and Calamity everywhere will appear ten
times and hence there is a claim one
cannot use this potentially identifying
information on the left to identify a
person and and identify which row
belongs to a person okay so for instance
now when this neighbor that comes from
zip code two three four five six because
age and sex were suppressed now maybe I
couldn't tell whether this person had
the heart attack or viral disease okay
but notice that would can this does not
always happen for instance in this case
the disease is the same regardless so I
cannot tell which role belongs to the to
which person that they have the same
sensitive information so baby they are
not protected so well and indeed people
have noted that and suggested variants
of key anima T which called L diversity
L diversity will make sure that on the
right hand will not have something like
here in the two person having the same
disease the closeness and so on but they
are all variants of County County is
quite a popular measure the numbers of
papers written about unanimity are quite
it's quite huge and has been used in
with with a lot of real real life data
the second technology I want to mention
briefly is differential private privacy
this is a measure that what suggested I
seen that work sherry I don't straighten
myself in 2006 and the best way maybe to
see this it's a definition of privacy
it's not a particular technique and the
definition requires the following in the
real world data is fed into an analysis
and we've seen outcome and I'm worried
in the world world because my data is
part of this data my sensitive
information is there and then there is a
chance that through the analysis some
information about me would be leaked
right so ideally I would want to see the
same analysis happen because I like
science or because I think this is an
analysis of an important force national
security or whatever that I would feel
better if my data was not included in
the analysis because then the analysis
could not leak it in could not lick
anything about me directly about me into
the outcome not like any information
that is specific to me into the outcome
and differential privacy is a
mathematical definition that formalizes
this disease right and not only for me
but for any participant in the dataset
okay and this is formalized by saying
that we wanted that the real-world
outcome would be very similar to the
ideal world outcome and because in the
ideal world outcome my specific
information could not be leaked so would
be in the case in the real world outcome
okay
this is formulated mathematically and
there is a measure of similarity between
these outcomes and it is the type of
similarity is chosen carefully so that
to make sure that chances of every bad
event like the probability that I will
not be issued insurance or that I will
not be accepted to to a school or that I
would be arrested
the chances of every such event
the similar in my ideal world and in the
real world and I will not get into the
math of how actually to do that but what
differential privacy captures is the
intuition that things could be learned
about me because I'm similar to other
people I'm human so or everything that
you learn about humans on the bottom on
the top on the bottom okay it's also
about me it's not that no information
about me is learned in this outcome but
information that is specific to me is
omitted there and hence cannot be
learned about me because this happens in
my DL world this will also if the
analysis is differentially private this
will also happen in the real world now
some related work combines between tries
to to bridge between legal or or
normative concepts and technical
concepts so maybe the first one to
mention is the work by Helen eastbound
but she's one of the organizers I
understand which is a framework for
reasoning about privacy and the
reasoning is about norms that that speak
about information flows between context
a context is like your like your home or
your doctor's office and so on and norms
talk about how information could flow
between different contexts and
differential privacy one one important
of the version that Helens now made is
that the the same the the revealing of a
piece of information would be considered
privacy preserving in one context and
not in another context for instance when
you go to your banker if your banker
would for some reason know something
about your medical condition that may
feel as reaching your privacy whereas if
that would happen when you go to to your
doctor or deed that would be acceptable
actually this is what you want to happen
so in different contexts different
information could be revealed and
contextual integrity is ephemeral for
written about privacy in such a complex
world world and there's been work to try
to formalizing in logic some aspects of
contextual integrity and to specify and
reason rigorously about norms of
transitions of personal information its
context of medical data another project
that is currently happening at Harvard
is Robert lawyers which i think is a
fascinating project where the idea here
is to learn about a dataset and
automatically generate a license for
researchers who download this data set
from social science data repository this
is also part of Harvard's privacy tools
project and what's common today is to
that is that they use logic as as as the
underlying language but then in this
logic that referred to predicates like
predicates are functions to you that
evaluate to true or false okay in here
is the one example from the first work
this is the predicate contains MPT this
wouldn't evaluate to true if message m
is about an individual P and it contains
an attribute T and similarly in the
robot lawyers project they have
predicates like FERPA identifiable and
the S is either set which would be value
to true if the Dare said D if the data
set is identifiable according to FERPA
but what both projects don't do is to
define these concepts these predicates
mathematically so making a decision of
whether a message M actually includes
information about an individual P and
what this is
actually imply something about in in
attribute II this is a very very trick
team if not impossible and similarly
from the legal description in surp I
think it's quite hard to make a
determination whether a deficit is
identifiable according to that standard
now in some work with is at Harvard we
tried to bridge some of these
differences in particular we looked at
FERPA and we extracted a very
conservative mathematical definition of
privacy from FERPA which conservative
here means that probably our definition
is much much more restrictive than what
the FERPA regulator meant okay so it's
kind of we're attacking the definition
to an extreme there were many reasons
for doing that that I will not be able
to describe now but once we had this
mathematical definition which likely
covers a lot more than what the
regulator meant we could also provide a
mathematical proof that pressure privacy
the use of differential x satisfies this
definition in hence we believe this is a
strong argument in favor of claiming
that the use of official privacy could
is satisfies the requirement in FERPA
for making it a set not identifiable
okay and this in particular may be
useful for understanding this predicate
prefer by identifiable that I mentioned
in the previous slide and I afraid I
won't have time to say more about this
project
so let me now get yep privacy is some
looks desirable because have this rather
clean idea versus real world comparison
but issues that in fulfilling it it's
like exceedingly and it's very strong
between him so I think things here you
have a weaker detention deeper
definition there's extract it from some
legal language somewhere it isn't the
question of okay so maybe this is
another definition maybe it's less
desirable but at least it is maybe the
spherical purple should want to try to
say like okay what can we come up with
like a broader set of tools that lets us
do more absolutely right the
differential privacy is a very strong
requirement which limits the use that
you can make out of data and a lot of
the research in the sense of privacy in
like a formal research and privacy is
directed at understanding exactly what
are the limits that you can how much you
can extract for me they said while
maintaining a reasonable our sense of
privacy and we were very far from
answering this the work we did here the
fact that we that because differential
privacy is such a strong requirement we
could be extremely conservative in
extracting that mathematical definition
and you wouldn't be surprised that even
we did not directly push for the front
surprise we got something that is very
close to differential privacy is
equivalent to it so this will not this
unfortunately I would love this to to be
able to give us a definition that is
still still allowable by FERPA and
weaker than the first part allows more
in terms of but but honestly this this
is not the case what I would love to say
is others coming with a similar analysis
taking very carefully looking very
carefully about the legal texts and
acting from a - the hints were they they
were they're scattered all over the
place in the in the regulation itself
and also in the guidance tax documents
to collect all these in order to make
potentially a weaker definition but
justified by by the legal text and then
we could compare the definitions and and
ask ourselves what are they the other
one is something that we like and
hopefully some of these attempts will
result in in in definitions that would
survive scrutiny so this is exactly what
I would love to see here I don't think
what we got is probably strong very
strong definition which means it's a
definition that if you satisfy it you
satisfy purpo but it's not necessary
probably not necessary to satisfy to
satisfy FERPA so we have an argument of
sufficiency but not of necessity here
and it will be interesting if to see if
we can develop an argument that is
closer to necessary and sufficient or
maybe something that is necessary to
come from the other side even without
the sufficiency so that we can now close
the gap but yeah this is something I'd
love to see like if this group will
develop that definition and I'm all for
it and and by the way this is also about
this this part of the talk where I will
tell about Morrison work with Elana
Cohen where we looked at notion from the
GDP are the singling out and which I
will give you the legal tax in in a few
minutes and we came up with a definition
we are four reason we did not call our
concept singling out to call it a
different name predicate singling out
with the purpose that we understand that
this may not completely reflect the what
what the regulator meant and
we hope that others will come with other
versions of singling out again justified
mathematically and legally so that we
compete we can compare these notions and
decide which one we want to to continue
with okay so let me so let me now into
this
so the general dem protection regulation
is currently what many people see as
like a strong privacy regulation in the
EU the full title is written here it's
regulation of the protection of natural
persons with regard to the processing of
personal data and on the free movement
of such data in repealing directive 95
they they are protected Protection
Directive so in May 2018 the their
protection directive of 1995 was
repealed and the gdpr came into effect
we all got these emails telling us that
we consent to whatever and because we
got these emails we know that our
privacy is protected much better now
right now interestingly we think many
people think about the GDP are as as the
privacy regulation that word privacy
appears there are exactly zero times and
so it's their protection regulation you
could think the Data Protection is why
there or narrower than privacy or has
other real relationship to privacy but
this is not directly about privacy on
the other hand the the free movement of
information is is this is a phrase that
appears many times in regulation and
also in the title so just to think about
that about what what the emphasis is
nevertheless I think the GD P R is a
good step like in terms of its it's
probably better than the regulations we
have in the US
the concept of singling out the GTR
begins with article 1 which the middle
delineates the the scope of the
regulation and they say this regulation
lays down rules relating to the
protection of natural persons would
regard to the processing of personal
data okay so if somebody holds personal
data or processes personal data then
this regulation applies and then in
article 4 they continue and explain what
personal data is this a personal data
means any information relating to an
identified or identifiable natural
person an identifiable natural person is
one who can be identified directly or
indirectly and then in another part of
the document in a recital there is some
explanation of what it means to identify
a person and they say to determine what
a natural person is identifiable
accounts should be taken of all the
means reasonably likely to be used such
as singling out to identify the natural
person directly or indirectly so if we
read this if you can single out in the
data then that data is identifiable and
hence the gdpr applies you have to there
are all these rules there that you have
to comply with this natural person
versus synthetic person yeah I don't
know I mean I mean it's a good point I
guess it's it's a natural person versus
in organization that's my guess but
again I'm not a lawyer so I may be wrong
about this
so just a couple more things about this
every cycle 26 like that appeared also
in the Data Protection Directive that
was repealed by the GDP are would
exactly the same text except for the
addition of the example of singling out
okay so somebody partly thought that it
is important to add it to the original
or subtle 26 and add singling out as an
example another thing is that there is
no other example given there so that the
latest after thing is now just emitting
an omission of text up that is not
relevant for the presentation but it
does not have an exist it does not
mention another kind of threat to data
okay singing out is an example but we do
understand the singing out may not be
the only way to identify data because
they say such as singling out so the way
that other means for identifying data or
for creating risk in data are also
relevant and need to be they could be
considered reasonably likely to be used
and hence nits need to be taking into
account yeah I will only speak about
thinking out today trying to understand
this this concert
no so the gdpr again I I'm I don't want
to answer the legal question so take
this with a grain of salt but the gdpr
duu rights
terminate roughly when you when you die
what would you say to your data there
are there are also other limitations but
but the natural person has to be alive
well there are limitations but but but
they don't have the same protections and
again take my answer with a grain of
salt because I'm not a lawyer maybe the
best thing I learned to say by working
with legal scholars is that I'm not a
lawyer okay and now you you would think
that I will find another recital 727
that explain what singling out is but
unfortunately this is the only
occurrence of the of this perf words in
the text so I have to go elsewhere and
one place to go is is the following so
that they deputy the Data Protection
Directive has said a working part it's
called the article 29 working party and
this is a working party with a lot of
experts and they produced a lot of very
useful documents explaining concepts
from the Data Protection Directive and
in particular they have a couple of
documents that relate to the question of
identifying identifying individuals in
data okay and risks that that
individuals may have in the data and
also examining the technologies that
could be used to mitigate these risks
and what the article 29 working party
says as regards indirectly identified or
identifiable person so this is exactly
the question that we're asking here this
category
typically relates to the phenomenon
of unique combinations with a small or
large in size okay name mates have not
been necessary in all cases to identify
individual this may happen when other
identifiers are used to single someone
out so if if there are dominations of
this article 29 working party also apply
to the gdpr and there is a question
about that I have told me but if they
apply if this then we understand that
singling out does not mean that you
actually can name a person but maybe you
can identify a person by a combination
of attributes furthermore as I said they
examine a collection of of technologies
and for us
you see they also look at two other kind
of risk which I will not touch upon
today but for a so far as the left-hand
side of this table is relevant and in
particular they look at our key
anonymity and with respect to calamity
the answer the question is singling out
still risk they say no it's not a
similarly L diversity which is a variety
of care limiting and what if I shall
privacy they say it the answer is not
conclusive here
I think that overall by referring to
singling out their GTR seems to to put a
higher bar on privacy than what is
usually considered anonymize data and I
think that's good
and you could ask yourself why is it
that they did that and here are two
answers that I made up
one is that singling out is a stepping
stone towards re identification in most
of their identification attacks first
they single out and so I think it's me
it makes sense to stop there and not a
require for a very identification but
also because singling out can create
other kinds of threats in particularly
singling out it suffices in many cases
for treating different personas
different
now so now we this is our starting point
we would like to understand or formalize
mathematically what singling out means
and there has been one trial in a paper
by Paul Francis and others were they
define tickling out isolation they say
you manage to single out in a dataset if
there is exactly one person that has
these attributes let me give you an
example so let's say that this is kind
of a Netflix award the data set it's
completely fake we made it up we have
here three persons with the movies that
they watch in writing and so on and here
are three isolation examples for
instance this is only one row in this
database of a person who watched the
movie distinct and then there is exactly
one row of a person who watched Moulin
between February and March them and
there's exactly one row of a person that
doesn't satisfy the other two conditions
so these are three ways to isolate in
this data set okay and you could ask
well single line singling out is indeed
isolation so for that let me put forward
a simple a simple model let's assume
that the Dare set has n rows and they
are drawn from some underlying
distribution probability distribution B
and technically I will assume that this
is an iid distribution this is a
restriction that we don't know how to
get around but so it may weaken our
definition and then this data is put
into some mechanism or analysis and
there is something that is published and
the adversary has access to the
published information and outputs a
predicate a predicate is the description
that evaluates to true or false and this
is a predicate on the possible values of
the original data set not Y but X okay
and now we could say the adversary's
goal is given the published data to
isolate in the der set X
put a predicate that matches exactly one
row one person in the dev ascetics and
here's a definition attempt we could say
that the mechanism is secure against
signalling world if no adversary manages
to isolate except for very tiny
probability okay
negligible probability and we have good
reasons to think that this actually
coincides with what some of the
regulators in Europe thought the only
problem that it's very easy to show that
this is impossible to do okay so this is
a big problem and let me give you an
example why is that consider what we
call a trivial aggressor so let's look
at the adversary that does not get any
information about the underlying dataset
okay can such an adversary isolate in
the desert such a nice other survival at
another set with non-negligible
probability and unfortunately the answer
is yes it's quite easy if the other side
chooses a predicate the description that
matches a random one over n fraction of
the universe then a simple mathematical
argument shows that the adversary
managers to isolate not with a
non-negligible probability but with
probability of services about 37%
okay very high probability and so the
other so I can isolate without seeing
anything about the desert and succeed
with high probability this just kills
the naive definitional attempt now you
may be worried that the adversary knows
too needs to know too much about the
underlying distribution in order to do
that but luckily we have worked from
randomness extraction and it's a fascist
that this distribution has moderate mean
entropy actually log in all the log and
base of of entropy surfaces and then we
can use the leftover hash lemma in order
to
yeah well you should sort of address
this at the miniature me but dad spent
limit to which roads you can look at
right because for example in your
previous example you had a road number
so I gotta say look at row number one so
obviously that column sorry there's
certain columns that are not yeah
sorry so I should have removed them
identifying by wrong number is illegal
wrong number it's not something that you
take a ID from the distribution yeah
now in typical databases there would be
a lot of minions repiy typical databases
are interesting what's that yeah yeah
that would work if that's your
underlying distribution that's the
distribution of where it's very easy to
isolate so this attack the tool a
dresser exists as long as there's enough
bit entropy in the underlying data set
and this does not have to be much mirror
for we only log n bits there is a
privacy violation if I say that there is
a woman who smokes and does this and
that so if there is such one woman
existence the violation you wouldn't I
don't know whether it exists or not
right person the data says you have no
proof of it you just pose so here in
isolation I don't require that you would
know that you were right but in many
cases once you can isolate a person
checking whether that is actually a
person in the desert like you have a
potential isolation checking what it is
such a person exists is not such a big
deal so I think it does make sense to
say that if you managed to isolate with
non-negligible probability but anyway
this this definition is just don't not
attainable and we will try to fix it
okay so this this game would achieve an
adversary relied very heavily on my
ability to to choose the predicate that
has weighed about one over and yes it is
achievable just not in nearly as many
you want right I mean suppose your
database is like one bit for road that
says whether or not your salaries yeah
right but how many databases do you know
that have just that only one bit is
collected about a person we process the
database know that you could you could
use Karin administration and just erase
all the data make every Road this is the
same but is this something that you will
actually yes so if you manage to reduce
the the the mean entropy in the data
below log n then it may be that this
data set is robust against against
isolation maybe this is not of course
it's a necessary condition not
sufficient but but in most cases your
goal is to extract as much information
as you can from the layer set not to to
erase the most of the data
yeah and this is why I would say it's
impossible
okay so so this driven attack relied on
an ability to to to pick on a predicate
that has weight to an event maybe we can
restrict the attacker to pick a
predicate with a different weight
working other than one over N so if the
predicate has a baseline wsre has a
weight w then a simple calculation
actually repeating the same calculation
shows that the Trivium attacker then
manages to isolate with this expression
on the right don't don't worry too much
about it because I have the table here
which means that if the weight is around
1 over n it comes to the very end then
you get you managed to isolate with one
of our polynomial probability or at the
extremes 37% but if you if they if work
wire that this that this predicate will
have negligible weight then the baseline
is negligible so this is a case where
there is a chance that that definition
is meaningful and similarly if the
weight is much higher than one over here
okay so here's our definition simplified
this is security against predicate
singling out and again we call the
traffic at singing out and not a killing
out because we think there is room for
others to come up with the finishes to
analyze this and maybe come up with
other definitions that we'll be able to
compare and we say that M is secure
against predicate chickening out if no
adversary can with non-negligible
probability output a predicate that
matches exactly one row in the desert so
it isolates but also this predicate has
weight that is bounded away from 1 over
N
and this will also work like if the
database is really restricted then you
can eyes you cannot isolate truth okay I
don't care about this
now given the definition we can analyze
its properties and two properties we'll
learn from a history of looking at
differential privacy that are important
are the resilience to post-processing so
if if an attacker
further processes outcome of the death
of the data set that should not create a
risk and the outcome of a mechanism that
you're not creative risk yes the way I
mean the N squared if you go back to the
previous table so our heart those other
two also like the one of our NC is
founded away from one over n right oh
you're right
so we could parameterize it I just I
just put negligible just for simplicity
I saved on some Greek lettering on on my
slide that's honest
so we can analyze the properties of the
definition it's very easy to see that
this definition is resilient to
post-processing and the second thing
would like to check is what our self
composites what happens if we have two
mechanisms each by itself secure against
predicate signaling out if we put them
together as a single mechanism is it
still secure against predicate singing
out in turns out the answer is no the
definition does not self compose and the
proof is quite simple look at the data
set so it has n values here and if the
first mechanism that we will create it
just uses the end the first n minus 1
rows of the mechanism and you need a
little more juice there but essentially
it extracts a random secret from from
these guys okay and we can prove that
this if you do it right that this is a
queue again thread predicate singing out
the second data and the mechanism that's
the same okay but uses the secret to
encrypt the last row of the data set
okay again by itself we can prove that
is secure against get singing out but if
you put both of them together then
clearly one can isolate the last row of
the data set can decrypt the the outcome
of the second of the second mechanism
and if the data has sufficient entropy
then this is a valid state door for me
the predicate have access heroes 1 to n
minus 1 when it's pressed the predicate
is not have access to them the predicate
that the adversary has access to this
this is one case that's the outcome of
the first mechanism or today's that's
the outcome of the second mechanism in
both cases does not have access to the
dear self but if the adversary has
access to both of them
he learns the last the last row of the
leadership the predicate that the
adversary would output is exactly what x
equals the XOR of these two things
after seeing the outcome of the
mechanism so if we combine both
mechanisms the adversary sees both s and
s XO X X N and hence lands X N and can
isolate
and how does that have a sailor has
as is the outcome of the first mechanism
sxo accent is that don't know again the
mechanism adjust output something so if
we combine these two mechanism will lose
piece of security and we also have an
example where which is more natural
because you may say you know we don't
usually do extraction from the first but
but we can actually use just count
mechanism mechanism that that do counts
and each of them is secured against
getting you out this is a little more
than login mechanisms but when we
compose them together then we'll lose
the security against for the cat singing
out and then we think that this says a
lot more than about our our definition
but it says something about singling out
because these are very natural
mechanisms these are mechanisms that
produce a very simple statistics about
the data just count how many people have
an attribute okay so these this attack
is likely to hold not only against our
definition but probably against any
reasonable definition of singling out
what you were getting after right if you
instead of having one mechanism if you
you know produce several mechanisms
which output just one bit 1 bit 1 bit 1
bit and you're saying that even with
just simply counts which had output of
log n bits with enough of them you can
even celebrate in opposition
yeah
okay so I want to conclude with two
things first I want to go back to this
question what are they these two
technologies protect against predicates
singling out and to think about what are
the consequences of this statement okay
so we can prove that differential
privacy protects against predicates
singling out okay I will not show the
proof now but the proof is I have some
connection so it reveals something
interesting about relationship between
singling out predicates singing now and
the generalization properties of
differential privacy which is a recent
line of work begin by this work by the
Wartortle in 2015 but it shows that
definitely shows that the first row
types it protects against predicates
single out this particular definition
well respect you can limiting the story
is interesting because this is a
technology that the article 29 working
party thought protects against singling
out and what we claim is it does not
protect against predicates singing out
okay so why how does that happen
this is a really simplified picture of
of the of the of the attack think about
it they're set like here would n rows
and we apply randomization for in this
example so we get something that every
row appears three times or more okay but
usually it will appear three times
because the a no and the key anonymous
is tries to squeeze as much information
as decay they can from the data okay and
because they try to so this is just a
requirement for anonymity each we can
think about each of these rows as
defining a predicate and actually in
some of the literature it's exactly
defined this way and the predicate on
the data itself has weighed more than K
over N okay but
and here the predicates in this case but
because anonymizer tries to suppress as
little as possible as possible they try
to squeeze as much information as
possible from the data typically the
weight of a predicate is going to be
negligible now if that is the case we
are just one step behind actually
forming an attack how do we do that
let's use the trivial attacker but now
instead of packing it an asset of size n
the trivial attacker will attack is
their sense of size K so needs to to
choose a predicate I call the P to be
all with one weight one over K roughly
now here's P trivial now let's assume
the attacker outputs the last predicate
that that he learns from the three
anonymizer in conjunction with P trivial
only the weight of this predicate is
less than the weight of three of P hence
its tiny by our assumption but this
predicate manages to isolate with
forbidding about 37% in this small group
and hence with probability about the
recent percent the resulting critical
also isolate so we get a predicate that
isolates and has a tiny weight and hence
this contradicts security against
predicate singing louder
now can we go back and ask whether this
this mathematical game has implications
for GDP our compliance and we believe
that that yes
want to be careful about that first the
positive results the fact that
differential privacy still a few more
minutes okay
but thanks for not buying me the
positive results we think have
restricted implications first the
definition we have I mentioned the fact
that we in the definitional way we
simplify the game we say that the Dare
set is is chosen IID okay so maybe this
definition is too weak with respect to
what the GDP our regulators meant okay
and hence a definition is too weak then
the prevention of predicate singing out
is necessary but not maybe may not be
sufficient okay so the fact that
differential privacy satisfies predict
this requirement
Piersol security does not directly say
that it satisfies the gdpr requirement
we need to do more research in order to
convince ourselves that this is the case
but because the definition is kind of
weakened the negative results are
meaningful
we're as I said were strict at the scope
that a cure the data set is chosen iid
and furthermore the attacker has no
luxury knowledge okay so this
strengthens the negative results and we
believe that this shows that calamity
probably does not align very likely does
not provide sufficient protection
against singing out okay and in the
proof that I showed the how the attacker
wore shows that actually why this is the
case in a sense committee provides the
attacker would most would hardest part
okay that is needed in order to to do
the predicate singing loud once the
attacker has the outcome of the three of
the Karen on you miser
just needs to also apply a true
attack here combine them together and
also we have singled out in this so back
to this table we believe that if article
29 working party will reconvene that
they would reconsider these conclusions
here and let me summarize now what we've
seen we began with the legal concept
from the GD P R and we analyzed it in
order to get a technical concept of of
seeing a single out okay and then this
technical concept informed aspect with
respect to the legal concept in its
consequences in more detail we began
with GDP our notion of singling out from
it we developed a definition of
predicate singing loud security now in
this world in the mathematical world we
could examine this definition and show
that it is resilient to to
post-processing but it is not self
composed and this also gave us some
insight into the notion of singing out
in the GDP our because the attack that
we have there is quite natural and
probably holds with respect to many
renewable definitions of singling out so
maybe this is an essential issue with
this this concept of singing out does
not mean that it's a bad concept but it
means that by itself it's probably
insufficient to one need to add more
requirements in order to get a
reasonable protection okay then we
examined these two technologies
randomization is not peaceful secure and
we think this likely means that it does
not prevent the GDP our style of
singling out and differential privacy is
PSO secured but that only gave some
evidence that the first privacy prevents
GDP are singling out but this is not
conclusive
we need to be careful about our
conclusions and I think here are a list
of some of the references for this talk
[Applause]
this collective like maybe purchases
three or thickness three there's another
it's a distinguished field that's fine
yes time series they've done and I
wonder if or acknowledging or discussing
species not just identity but also time
can give more refined definitions that
they will be more easily applicable or
it wasn't really mentioned does each
person had what like one record here
yeah yeah this is a very good question
so in I can only say what happens in the
differential privacy in the first policy
kind of you could you would think about
the record of a person or something that
is accumulated over time but the privacy
exactly but but and in the requirement
the personal policies with respect to a
person's entire role whether it never
mind if it hasn't been written yet okay
and I think that's that's a careful and
right way to to act with respect to
privacy over time but it also limits
what you can do with with data that is
collected over time so it makes sense to
search for formalisms that take time
explicit into account explicitly not
implicitly as in differential privacy
and see whether you can get something
that is more permissive to the best of
my knowledge we don't have anything like
that
it talks about this static databases or
did you'd appear to my understanding and
again I'm not a lawyer is does exactly
what you say it does not go into this
level of details to to distinguish
between data that is collected over time
and otherwise in terms of what is
reformed and what is required in terms
of protection again I'm talking about
with respect to that concept I was
looking at it may be that there are
provisions in the gdpr about there are
the church that is fully collected over
time in terms of security and so on but
this is not these are not areas that I
was looking at specifically
I think maybe why they think MIT is fine
that definition is the singling out can
be also taught us given the data set and
the set of the attributes can identify
someone so I think some people assume
that k equal to 1 to D satisfies similar
definition yeah what I cannot guess what
they meant of course but I can send two
things one is it sounds eternity that
calamity
protects against singing aloud and to
the best of our knowledge from the
documents who've read we did not see it
careful analysis as we did on our system
as we did with respect to the technology
in the in the document written by the
article 29 working party what I'm
worried about interpretation of the kind
that you are saying is that they are
limited because can limit e is a
criteria that works when you get a
database and then since you you you also
output it they're set just that you
erase some of the data but in many of
that analysis what your output is not
another data set it's it's a statistic
it's it's a machine learning model it's
whatever the new thing is and if you
restrict yourself to say what happens
with the input and output of the
mechanism assuming that it that out
would satisfies this this format then
restricts the entire view to a small
collection of analysis and I think we
need to think about it within a much
more general way
let's um
[Applause]